الاجتماع البدوي هو احد الميادين علم
الاجتماع العام ويهتم بدراسه المجتمعات
البدويه في مراحل تطورها من مرحله الرعي
والتنقل الى مرحله الاستقرار ومن ثم الى
مرحله التحضر
والحقيقه انا اجريت دراسه اكاديميه في
جامعه دمشق تناولت فيها قبيله عنزه
الوائليه فدرست هذه
القبيله في مراحل تطورها التاريخي
والاجتماعي والسياسي ما بين الجزيره
العربيه وبلاد الشام واخدتها كنموذج
للعمل اذا
اعتقد حتى الماجستير والدكتوراه في
الماجستير في قبيله عنزي في القيم
المجتمعيه الحقيقه العنوان مثير وتعتقدنا
دكتور كمان الباحثين الاجانب غير العرب
اوروبيين وغير الاوروبيين بس بشكل خاص
اوروبيين ايضا وفدوا الى المنطقه وكتبوا
عنها الكثير سواء على شكل رحلات رحله
بلغريف ورحله داوتي وغيرهم او على شكل
دراسات احيانا او مزج بين الامرين يعني
معايشه ودراسات يعني على ذكر عنزه تذكر
دراسه التشيكي
موزيل اللي سموها لاخلاق رواه وعاداتهم
مسمى نفسه موسى الرويلي
دراسه وغيرهم لكن هل تعتقد ان الباحث
العربي ابن البيئه لديهم ميزه مثلا اذا
درس هذه الاشياء يعني تميزه عن الباحث
الاجنبي الفرق ما بين دراسه الباحث العربي
او دراسه المستشرق الذي اتى الى المنطقه
العربيه لاجراء دراسه هو الاهداف الاختلاف
في الاهداف فالباحث العربي يتناول
دراسه هذه المجتمعات للوصول الى حقائق
تاريخيه تفيد في توثيق تاريخه بينما
المستشرق كان هد فه هدف سياسي لوجستي
بامتياز واحيانا استخبارات واحيانا
استخباراتي عرفت كيف